los pasajeros escaparon por las ventanas
y por el techo del tren después de que
se descarrilara dentro de un túnel a lo
largo de la costa de este de taiwán
según el ministro de transporte de
taiwán en el tren viajaban casi 500
personas y no 350 como se reportó
inicialmente estaba sentada en el
pasillo y me caía al suelo cuando el
tren se estrelló los informes locales
sugieren que el accidente fue causado
por un camión que cayó en los rieles al
desviarse de la carretera
los socorristas trabajarán durante
varias horas para rescatar a los
pasajeros que quedaron atrapados dentro
de los vagones que se derrumbaron tras
el impacto el tren viajaba a lo largo de
la montañosa costa este de taiwán un
popular destino turístico famoso por sus
túneles el accidente ocurrió en un día
festivo cuando la gente viajaba a casa
para el festival de limpieza de tumbas
de cuatro días de taiwán con decenas de
muertos y heridos es el peor desastre
ferroviario del país en más de 40 años